business as usual business as usual
everybody it's Charlie time to get
whelmed young justice season 3 is back
this is going to be my non-spoilery
review of the first part of the season
because there's a lot of confusion I'll
explain how to watch it when episodes
are dropping in how many episodes are
dropping so they've already explained
all the details don't worry it's gonna
be awesome it's the best it's ever been
there have been a lot of upgrades in the
creative the way they make the episodes
in the actual characters themselves
within the story so we'll do a new round
of that DC streaming service giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite Young
Justice moment on the video so a couple
years ago they canceled the show after
season two because the toys aren't
selling and that's how a lot of animated
children's TV shows make their money the
way television shows make money is
really complicated don't worry about it
it gets canceled by Cartoon Network and
you know traditional broadcast TV show
but what happens is is all the episodes
go to Netflix people start binging it a
bunch of new people find it and it
develops a new audience
so because Warner Brothers and DC comics
wanted to develop this DC streaming
service for DC specific content they
decided well if people really love this
and they're streaming it a lot it would
be perfect fit for our new streaming
service thus Young Justice was
resurrected as season 3
there'll be 26 episodes total they're
breaking it into two halves so the first
half of the season is gonna start airing
on Friday three episodes per week till
they burn through the first half then
the second half of the season which will
be a different story arc will air later
during the summer if you are around four
Titans or if you try to watch episodes
of titans the way you watched that will
be the same way that you watch Young
Justice episodes I think there are a lot
of younger people that are just confused
about the concept of the DC streaming
service and how they're windowing
content around the world so what happens
is is if you want to watch Young Justice
season 3 episodes the only way to watch
that if you live inside the United
States is if you get the DC streaming
service those episodes will start
dropping on Friday if you live outside
the United States
just like for Titans you'll get episodes
through Netflix but I don't think that
Netflix will start airing those
episodes till way later this year so
like DC streaming service guess the
episodes they air all them then you get
to watch them on Netflix so if you want
to watch them right away as they air the
only way to do that is pretty much
through the DC streaming service if you
want episodes right away my
recommendation for you is just to try a
VPN so that you can pay for the DC
streaming service wherever you live so
you pay you get all the episodes you get
all these extra comics all that extra
content right as it airs that's probably
the best way to get those episodes each
of the episodes is about 24 minutes long
there's no commercials so you're getting
a little more content per an episode the
animation style is largely consistent
with what you saw during season 2 but
they have polished everything a little
bit more so it does look a little bit
nicer the biggest changes are in the
types of stories they tell because there
aren't any broadcast standards so the
themes the characters everything is just
a little more hardcore they typically
end episodes on a really WTF cliffhanger
moment then while the credits play
there's usually like an extra little
scene with a very somber or lullaby song
in a moment that kind of makes you cry a
little bit but also balances out those
WTF cliffhangers that push you into the
next episode but like I said they're
airing three episodes per week so it's
not like you have to wait a long time to
find out what happens in the next
episode the show itself has tried to
evolve with its audience so like if you
were a little bit younger when you
started watching Young Justice on
Cartoon Network you're older now you're
watching like Rick and Morty more anime
series stuff that's a little more
hardcore the show has grown with you so
you'll appreciate the new tone but it is
not joyless like it's not ultra hardcore
there's still a lot of comedy a lot of
the relationships have evolved between
the characters I don't want to get into
spoilers because this is supposed to be
a non-spoilery video but even though not
a whole lot of time has passed within
the universe since the end of season 2
the dynamics between the characters has
evolved quite a bit but just to explain
that season 1 actually I was incorrect
in my previous video I just misread the
dates on some of the shows so what
happens is is there's actually a big
Easter Egg for when season 3 picks up it
starts July 4th 2016 so you'll recognize
that as an Easter Egg for the very first
episode the pilot episode of Young
Justice took place on Independence
de 2010 July 4th 2010 so it's six years
to the day when season three picks up
but in the context of the season two
finale when Vandal Savage is meeting
with Darkseid in this season two end
credits scene that's July 5th 2016 so
season 3 actually picks up a day before
they have that meeting so that's
important I'll talk more about that when
I do more spoilery Easter Egg videos
later this week after people have a
chance to actually watch the episodes so
no worries because there are a lot of
creative changes the characters all get
costume upgrades and dynamics of how the
Justice League and the Young Justice
characters operate within the universe
there is a prequel comic that's
available for free on the DC streaming
service that will explain what's
happened during this like kind of short
time jump because there are a couple of
weeks that go by during the course of
the first episode I don't know if a
later in the series there's gonna be
some giant time jumps to catch the
events of the show up to 2018 2019 the
creators haven't said anything about
that so for the most part the first big
chunk of the season takes place during
2016 without getting into spoilers I've
talked a little bit about what the story
is about about how you met a human
trafficking is a big thing and it's all
just a continuation of what's going on
in this post credit scene with Darkseid
and Vandal Savage in the light so the
light is still the main villain there's
a ton of brand new characters the roster
is a little bit different in the first
episode like they have a whole bunch of
characters but for the most part the
Young Justice team that you follow
through the first couple of episodes is
a little bit different than what you've
seen before but they do a good job of
explaining why and what everybody else
is actually doing you've seen a lot of
the trailers halo forager Black
Lightning is a really huge character the
first couple of episodes he's got a big
costume change it's also kind of funny
because Aqualad is a big character in
the first couple of episodes and Khary
Payton does the voice of both Aquaman
and black lightning and within the first
couple of moments they actually share a
couple scenes together so it's like the
same actor talking to himself so pay
attention to that because there are a
lot of voice actors on the show that
play multiple characters that appear in
the same episode probably one of the
best things I think about the first
couple of episodes is the way they make
it seem like business as
usual because you know like they even
build that into the first little clip I
posted the opening scene a little while
ago and there's that line from Nightwing
where he says business as usual the
reason they included that was the sort
of wink at the audience like hey you
know even though we got canceled a
couple years ago and we're back it's
still business as usual quote unquote
but within the context of the universe
it's also business as usual for all
these characters but so far after
watching the episodes is my favorite
season so far between season 1 2 & 3
we'll see if that's still the same after
the air the second half of the season
later this year but to compare first
half to second half because like I've
said in previous videos they're dividing
the episodes into two halves and it's
gonna be like a big story arc for the
first 13 episodes in a different story
arc for the second 13 episodes but it's
all season 3 so they T up a really big
mystery in the first couple of episodes
that they'll largely solve and deal with
in the first half of the season but in
doing that we'll uncover larger things
at play with Vandal Savage the light and
dark side that they'll solve the second
half of the season once you do have a
chance to see the episodes just let me
know what you think of all the new stuff
like well have you been watching the
trailers you get a pretty good feel for
what it's gonna be like because of the
weird way they're dropping episodes I'll
just look to you guys to let me know
what kind of videos you want me to make
for it so no worries just leave all your
requests in the comments below I know a
lot of people are wondering about Wally
West one of the biggest fan theories out
there is he ever coming back they do
address that during episode 1 so we can
talk more about that when we get to more
spoilery videos just be sure to check
the episodes out when they drop on
Friday however it is that you watch
Titans wherever you live in the world
that is the same way that you will watch
Young Justice season 3 episodes there
was a brand new flash trailer for
episode 10 I'll do a video for that next
it should be up in a little while
click here to rewatch the entire opening
scene from Young Justice season 3
episode 1 and click here for my brand
new Punisher season 2 teaser trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay whelmed i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]